okay how's it going everyone and welcome
to I didn't even I don't even let's go
well are you weren't supposed to pick
the same up but you have already played
this game that's a good tip don't
drinking drugs they say it's our
deducing I remember it's a sector my
guess I haven't like x1 I've only been
around Gomez Mitka army guard there
lived a powerful physically give me
to harness the power of all magics
ancient spells crafted in times long for
copy
with such knowledge he might enable the
visits of the old story magic to spread
it along how he's drinking coffee to
learn I'm not watching it but still
waiting no watch no I don't want to
watch it then skip it awesome loading
screen is awesome
I'm not a vampire
okay let's go
I'm pumped oh my god I'm so awesome yes
oh I'm used to moving with like QV na
what are you doing what are you doing
Falcon punch how do you how do I [ __ ]
punch hold shift and then we should just
do this ain't I episode I'm winning I'm
winning no I'm running when I run away
from you [ __ ] then we're only welcome
back err nope come back and make me a
sammich don't get together sorry I
forgot to go I was like I don't tell
them hey there do you do how hips knave
sticking bucks
punkin punching me sorry do you know the
way
we're going down
awesome music awesome BAE leaks did you
see my name Alex maybe what's going this
is the tutorial we could skip this if
you're switching back out
we're both face palming welcome but just
to obtain a staff and wear a sword
interact holy [ __ ]
oh my god for best stuff ever
holy [ __ ] this table wait we shouldn't
be killers
our self desirable surround smiles
ah what is read right holy [ __ ] what am
i dying why am i dying oh sorry bro how
I didn't do it I swear it wasn't me
good job we die on the tutorial shut up
look at this I'm healing you [ __ ] how
do I use the spell right click to and if
you can't take Mouse will you cast it on
yourself which mouse most weak if you
click it up good thing my my school my
sweat well this broken
i'ma charge in MA
okay I'm firing now go put it on fire no
not me nothing I'm sorry sorry I didn't
oh wow you're totally buying oh oh I
drown myself
where am I
you did come on kill yourself either am
thank you
charge
are you doing how are you son
know it careful okay okay yeah I'm
careful geez don't let you do the time
yeah you should let me do this all right
I didn't like to do
not on me okay I got on this Oh
yeah I'm a genius like I hear enough
you don't need it but stuff read the
textbook Oh
state Alchemist oh [ __ ] ah ah way that I
do well you're gonna put some fire on
yourself so you don't if you put if
you're wet and do it electrician your
heart your school oh that's what I did
so if you put the fire in yourself if
it's pressed fire and mouse real yeah F
mouse wheel yeah
not he'll um I don't want to hear myself
but till okay F
and mouse wheel and now you can use
penis
now you've got
no I got it oh yeah
it's Ahriman way I was doing a super
good job oh that was your father
this one thing you gotta hit both at the
same time that's difficult it's not even
possible do the AoE I think it's Mouse
Oh
he talking about Oh epics staff how do I
pick it up
you had the same I have to you picked up
my pistol
Alma
okay okay
dude that no wait do
to earth and lightning and impress my
eyes I'm on fire wait where is worried
you don't need water just okay earth
lightning I don't have house
acidity
actually I did
oh how is he doing take lightning yeah
and press shift right click there yeah
let's stand closer to top yeah no
comment
[Music]
okay maybe need more charge to light
there we go I did it myself with a
little help
now with this well you can shoot
lightning if you take it if you take
that beam and lightning
[Music]
fancy right hey am now gonna do this
useless be a hemorrhoid mm-hmm what is
calm are you are not on me okay oh oh
yeah I like you're slow
seriously
[Music]
no no no water
oh wait I put water on your bra don't
worry
I thought it was water four to five okay
toe box for hey let me blow this up no
dude move
and that yes I mad you speak okay okay
okay okay
this you pick that book up huh now you
can learn haste
it's a SF and then you have space in
your unexpressed and I'm gonna get
crushed
conserva
- there's a F okay I see it I see the
combination and then you click space
I'll click space little [ __ ] quick
space
Oh F
again let's kill these [ __ ]
Oh
- better
dude what how that this because you know
the cool spills battles melts
hey barrel cool
I'm not the barrel sorry what now don't
die on me please
I'm sorry it wasn't leave see I had
water prepared for you
I was actually gonna do it why don't you
burn those pearls how do I do like an
explosion
it'd take fire and earth okay uh-oh
uh-oh I need help with this guy actually
I don't I'm here
damn lookin I was crits nose easy
this nothing like I'm Gladys yeah Wow
tits interprets role hello are they talk
we should talk
I
do they
Oh what was that what is this
it's air I'm gonna shoot air on your
[ __ ]
Hey you loaded to the max ow okay noted
for the max
they like it yeah
look at that what did you do
Oh
oh I'm thank Liang Liang Liang Amaya
don't take my library stuff
my [ __ ] yeah took my [ __ ] stop yeah okay
you can hit some moose I never noticed
okay
mr. lost epic music is epic we learn
revive hey am babe a fanzine deliver
okay it was RF and fire let's do it
explosion time
how are they just still sitting that
today yeah and look at this
once again
looks let's enhance Sherlock Holm's
batch it's an open it suppressant for me
it's a penis yes
don't use my press middle-mouse yeah
thank you
Oh crash to desktop you did you see what
[Music]
[Applause]
and she's